Ami's in tulsa oklahoma hi ring Amy how
are you I'm good how are you better than
I deserve what's up well I am calling
because my husband lost his job this
summer
at the time we only had our emergency
fund in place there was about $600 in
there that's gone he quickly got a job
but we have lost a significant amount of
income and I am actually in school we
have four small children I'm going to
school to be a nurse and we are at a
point to where we are paying our monthly
bills but only that we have about twenty
thousand dollars in medical debt that we
are not currently paying on we have
started talking about possibly selling
our home and using the equity that we
have to pay off all debts and I wanted
to see what your thought was on that
what did he used to make it his old job
his salary was 72,000 and he had a
guaranteed $15,000 about this doing what
he don't swimming pools and what does he
make now now he is hourly he makes $20
an hour he has the ability to have
overtime but it's not consistent
sometimes he gets about 10 hours of
overtime a week sometimes it's more okay
why is the swimming pool business
substantially worse in Tulsa Oklahoma
than it was the swimming pool business
is still a good business he's actually
working for another full company mm-hmm
his he he just lost his position with
the company he was at really didn't have
anything to do with the pool industry so
he's with another pool builder now he
enjoys his job his goal enjoy his job I
don't enjoy his job he's trying to sell
his house to pay his bills
I think his job sucks industry I think
his job sucks him used to make 72,000
now he makes what 35:35
he's making $20 an hour so at least 41
if he only gets 40 hours a week that's
before taxes is this moving back into a
job is moving back into 70 and 80 there
is potential but we sounded very right
his his boss and the people that he
works with they have said that they have
great plans for him but I don't know
what that entails or when that will
happen
is there a competitor that has better
plans for him I don't think that's been
explored enough well I think it needs to
be before we start talking about selling
our house here's the thing there's only
one reason you're selling your home your
husband is underemployed right he's not
lazy he's not a bad guy he got fired for
some reason that we haven't discussed
whatever happened happened and it
knocked us it knocked his knees out from
under him emotionally and he's not quite
as confident and cocky as he was this
time last year right and I want him so I
want to swagger back me too yeah and
that way we don't have to sell the house
that way we don't have to sell Iran our
house right or if we're going to open
our own business that's fine you can
make 200 in the pool business pool
people actually build pools that don't
leak and show up when they say they're
going to show up are amazing mm-hmm it's
a dirty business no pun intended
it's a lot of shysters in the business
isn't there yeah I've been around it my
whole building my whole life and pool
people come and go man
good ones they make a mint because they
show up on time they do what they say
they're gonna do and you know the
technology is all improving they stay up
on the technology you know something
leaks they take care of it
stuff is actually done was supposed to
be done it's amazing but for some reason
that business attracts shysters and so
yeah I think you had to go in business
for himself so if we're going to sell
the house to get out of debt
we can going business for ourselves hey
cool I'm in do it but if we're gonna
sell if we're gonna sell our house
because we got the wind knocked out of
us and we're gonna make 40 instead of
making 80 when we're worth 80 to 200
because we lost our swagger I'm not in
you see the difference yeah yeah you got
this you don't what to do you know what
today this guy's this guy's better than
he thinks he is right now you need to
remind him of that okay right you know
his income doubled by this time next
year okay whether he's on his own or
whether he's doing whatever and if you
sell your house to take a step back to
get on solid ground let's do it with a
plan to go forward not a plan to
permanently resign the half the income
we used to make right and that's the
goal in mind
that's it wasn't in the early in the
conversation that is our plan okay and
we just if we sell our home and once we
have that solid kind of start fresh
foundation if that will give it's not
okay for it we're not doing that so that
he can make 40 though right we're doing
that so that he so that your debts gone
so you leapfrog forward both of you and
get your incomes back up to the
potential that God has for you in your
life you guys have the ability to make
$200,000 a year between the two of you
when you come out of nursing and he's
making 100 120 whatever you're making 60
or 80 you guys are gonna your income is
gonna be ridiculously good and you need
to get ready for that and cause that to
happen both of you you're on track to do
your thing I want him back up on his
feet to swagger and again hey thank you
for the call you got a good man there
you just got knocked down hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]